[Music]
should they treat you like dirt
if you happen to flirt in newsweek
writer kat rosenfield points to a new
survey reporting that 93
of women consider workplace flirtation
inappropriate
compared to 27 percent of men who said
it was sometimes acceptable
this doesn't include the less than one
percent who answered i am the governor
of new york
rosenfield points out what a huge change
this is from the 90s and early 2000s
when about 20 percent of people met
their spouses at work
i was one of them back then she notes
dating online was seen as something only
weirdos did
or while their wife was busy being an
aide to hillary clinton
now everything except online dating
where there's built-in consent for
flirting
is as creepy as my leopard print tank
top
and even except i didn't know whoever
wrote that knew about that
and even expressing interest in someone
in person is now a risk
rosenfield points to a 2018 article in
the atlantic by a woman who says she met
her
now husband in an elevator some women
thought the story was cute but other
women said
they'd be weirded out if a random guy
started talking to them in an elevator
i wonder if she's right how would an
elevator meeting go these days
uh what floor what excuse me disgusting
you're married right
fella was so right about it you know
what let's just go ahead and press the
floor for hr
i think we learned a lot there all right
[Applause]
carly i always find the idea of flirting
weird because
it's like who like it's kind of like i
don't even know what it is
it's like how do you like i'm gonna go
like i'm gonna go over and flirt with
this woman
like what is why don't you have a
conversation what is flirting i don't i
don't
i i don't go to this meta thing again
i'm old enough to know what it is
but i don't think i ever flirted i think
i was just my charming self
obviously yes um so what did they say 93
of women said that workplace flirting is
inappropriate a lot of them are lying
but they're also smart because what are
you gonna say like yeah like i go to
work to
get a date they're just no i don't i
don't do that yeah
um but the part of the article that said
that people feel uncomfortable
meeting people out now i think is that's
totally true
that is a chilling chilling face i know
some some i was talking to a girlfriend
who's single and she said that
uh she doesn't really know how to
interact with people
in a date like setting outside and
meeting them for like looking at their
profile
so i met my husband at a bar and when i
tell that story sometimes people are
like oh my gosh that's so
cute in old school yeah yeah how weird
is that yeah
and it sucks because there's so many
available men on the streets of new york
[Laughter]
i mean they're literally just lying all
over the place
you're a single woman you can just walk
out and scoop one of them
drag them home joe honestly you are the
probably the expert here this is this is
a topic that hit close to home i'm back
in an office now and
i'll tell you what the uh office ladies
are attracted to me like moths to a
flame
and the worst part is like i'm just so
smooth
i'm not trying to seduce anyone like
i'll say hi cat and to the ladies that
sounds like come hither
you recognize your power yeah with that
power comes great responsibility but
but i'll say this i think i think you
spend too much time behind the screen
and you lack the development of empathy
for other people and their feelings you
tend to make things all about you and
that happens in
harmless conversation but that also
happens in stand-up comedy
you tell a joke and someone uh doesn't
recognize that's a comedy club and a
comedian telling a joke they think
oh this is something about me this
person's trying to hurt me and it's like
no you're making this something that it
isn't yeah that's true that's true
i used to like you until you said this
you know um
yeah what do you uh um you know you uh
i'm trying to
uh see what i can say to you that would
not be offensive
when have you ever done that
what do you make of this information
okay i mean good job i think it's awful
kind of yeah i mean i mean it to be like
a little bit serious right like the me
too movement i thought was really
important talking about you know people
men
in positions of power who would use that
to you know harass subordinates who
felt like they couldn't do anything
about it because they did have all that
power
and now we've turned into oh he said he
liked my dress
and i was traumatized like no you
weren't and that
completely invalidates all of the real
and serious stuff
and i i think that that's awful yeah so
thoughtful
uh commentary on today's problems and
dilemmas among our younger people
thank you i got a big brain in here yeah
you do yeah you do
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else